bonsoir ici brillant au bois ce deuxième
tour des législatives qui s'approche à
grands pas dans un contexte tendu on
imagine que l'inquiétude est palpable
sur place oui je vous remercie de
m'avoir donné la balle
c'est vrai que nous sommes inscrits ce
qui n'est pas nouvelle cette idée de qui
a tué
je pense que le climat 2dans de tout au
climat de désertours sera plus ou moins
égales au même climat
je prenais tout mais naturellement d un
réel doute souffert ou sécurisé de la
nation respective et et l'entier de
l'onuci ainsi qu'un de sécurisation des
personnes et des biens est attirée sur
les candidats et de maturer d'année j ai
pas choisis aujourd'hui clairement l'a
entendu un dans ce sujet les populations
craignent une guerre confessionnelle 1
qui aggraverait encore plus la situation
déjà difficile de la centrafrique est ce
que clairement aujourd'hui selon vous on
peut l'éviter
cette guerre je pense qu'il y aura pas
de guerre
aujourd'hui nous avons une crise
sociopolitique août et a carrément et à
chaque fois on nous paraît sortir cette
pression de bien contre isuppli
oui c'est la gestion de la crise
entraîne ces gens de petite hutte de
guerre professionnel vous avez des rues
que aujourd'hui des syndicats il n'est
pas la cas qu'ils étaient des ennemis
d'hier soit disant là la guerre est un
logique de la diète concussion les
amener à rendre 6 août et sa grille de
paix tient ou de douze imams et
aujourd'hui six ans ensemble je pense
que raison ou là
long du bloc nous paraît de 16,2 de
guerre et ponte soit prêt nous avons
comme on appelle ça un coup d'état en
gestation
nous avons des bandes armées nous avons
un conflit en république centre
quelqu'un ou aux rafles de tarbes et ils
poussent à corriger ex au gel nous avons
aussi des étrangers et qui sont venus
par exemple tiers et/ou sida et ce après
oslo plus de bateaux que la rca et le
lopin culture de guerre tous les romains
d'eau 1 de tous genres anciaux des la
réputée de satrapi quelle teinte au
bénin pour exploiter l'or le diamant
piles et les sources 1 et par contre
c'est qu'un couple élise et la
coopération il toujours à moins de gris
des situations de déstabilisation au
point de ne pas accepter l'autorité
touche et ça permet de parier locales
élues de 2de bac est halal et de
continuer à pied est donc cette crise je
pense que parler de la compression ce
n'est pas au moment là là là là l'hôtel
nous avons rue comme à présent une crise
qui n'a jamais voulu ou alors la
solution la touche tous les munitions
nascar et dupont celle du pauvre
apporter comme en appel à poser de
vraies questions met le doigt sur le mot
à côté la solution du là et donc au
moins nous avons eu et qui est une crise
sociopolitique due par exemple à la main
par les chefs excepté la équilibres
sociaux et nourrit l socioculturel c'est
à compter la solution à cela on a vu que
la russie étaient sur place le rwanda
aussi mais aucun pays
dit occidental pour quelles raisons
selon vous moi je pense que la personne
à qui
l'achat d'une résolution de cette
tournée c'est d'abord lancé tant dans le
tableau nations-unies tous les ans à
l'occitan houblon confrères je trouve
beau c'est l'union européenne qui est là
dans le cas des eaux parmi les soldats
il était bien aussi les accompagnants
fait ça parce que je suis aussi tous de
constater que cette course
internationale les nations ski proposés
par toutes les familles san siro s'ils
l'ignorent il existe qu'il n'arrive pas
naturellement apporté de la situation et
vous outil on a obligé de se traiter
avec le force plus loin d'être passe ici
des autorités du rwanda au jeu dans ces
conditions selon l'onu la centrafrique
est le deuxième pays de l'eu moins
développés du monde
selon vous le nouveau président faustin
archange touadéra peut-il faire évoluer
les choses
le présent plan social en choisir un
avec déjà bien commun si quand il
appelle fais plus la décision tombait
pas à l'époque intégrer les loups armée
dont le gouvernement à rejeter le
premier à l'appui 10 ou celle de demain
pourquoi parce que c'était ce qu'il
fallait mais quand je l'avais commencé
par céder à la négociation de l'accord
plus tard excellent à cet accord qui a
en quelque sorte que toute la et c'est
cet accord qui sait 16 se tapant qui
après que aujourd'hui les groupes armés
se sont démultipliés nous avons par
exemple de tunnel bout groupes armés et
où la signature de ces accords on a su
que sélectionné quatorze autres bouts ou
intégrer le gouvernement et les autres
se sentaient lésés et nous avons tant
impressions je pense que la mort a
renversé un an plus tard
aujourd'hui qui ne peut pas exister en
tant qu'intellectuel et prétendre à des
postes de responsabilité c'est difficile
mais par contre c'est facile avec 16,1
en neuf ans que tu peux prendre des
armes et en contrepartie nez bouché des
postes de responsabilité et ce qui est
encore dangereux
donc c'est encore cette fois vous avez
des gens qui n'ont jamais été à l'époque
plus du thème qui s'est jamais montré
comment ils ont sauvé employés déclarent
généraux et qui témoin ou ou bien je
m'en voulais connaître leur avis assez
pour moi c'est de point de non retour et
ses deux boîtes des possibilités est un
pas en avant qu ils n'étaient bons
appels à l'unité militaire eux n'y sont
pas entraînés fort sur le maire et le
gouvernement
c'est là en plus perméable à permettre
leur apparent de beaucoup de choses
techniques et vittel de se douter d'être
arrimée n'as tu sors je dois jouer dans
celle de fitch ne sont pas obligés
merci en tout cas reste merci pardonnez
mon as compris le message on arrive même
mais malheureusement la fin de cette
interview mercière ici de briller en ré
beaux instants d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france pour évoquer la
situation de la centrafrique merci à
vous